Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. In der türkischen Süper League da passieren wundersame Dinge und über die wollen wir jetzt sprechen mit dem Chefredakteur vom Magazin Sokrates Fatih Demireli hier im Kurzpass. Fatih, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt. Mir geht's gut, aber ich habe mir neulich verwundert die Augen gerieben. Du kannst den Zeitpunkt auch ungefähr wissen, es war eine Minute, bevor ich dir bei WhatsApp geschrieben habe. Fatih, müssen wir vielleicht mal über die Süper Liga reden. Denn da ist so einiges passiert, was ich ehrlich gesagt nicht mitbekommen hatte. Schäm ich mich ein bisschen dafür. Unter anderem liegt Fenerbahce nach 16 Spieltagen auf dem Tabellenplatz 17, also auf einem Abstiegsrang. Und es führt eine Mannschaft die Liga an, Istanbul Basakse hier, von der ich das nicht erwartet hätte. Und das mit einigem Abstand, nämlich sechs Punkten. Lass mal so von oben nach unten ein bisschen durchgehen. Basakse hier. Was muss ich über die wissen? Wie kommt es, dass die bei 21 zu 7 Toren so deutlich die Liga anführen nach 16 Spieltagen?
Ähm, so komplett überraschend ist es jetzt nicht, dass sie Herbstmeister geworden sind, zum dritten Mal in Folge übrigens. In den letzten beiden Jahren sind sie aber nicht Meister geworden.
Jetzt fühle ich mich gerade richtig dumm. Und ignorant auch ein bisschen.
Ich wollte sie auch nicht nach einer Minute schon wieder auflaufen lassen, aber...
Nee, es ist aber gerechtfertigt.
Ja, also wenig überraschend, vor allem, wenn man auch die Tore, die also 21 Tore geschossen, sieben kassiert. Also ich glaube, man muss auf diese sieben kassiert sich da konzentrieren. Das ist natürlich schon überragend. Das ist auch das große Plus der Mannschaft. Sie ist sehr, sehr gut organisiert. Vom vielleicht bestem Trainer der Türkei, von Abdüla Aouji, der schon viele, viele Jahre bei diesem Verein arbeitet. Und ich glaube, der große Vorteil von Abdüla Aouji ist, neben vielen Sachen, die ich gleich auch ausführen werde, ist, dass er in großer Ruhe arbeiten darf. Es gibt ja keine Fans.
Ehrlich?
Was jetzt erstmal per se etwas sehr, sehr schlimm klingt, ist es auch.
Woher kommt das?
Der Verein ist tatsächlich der Verein der Istanbuler Großstadtverwaltung. Also der Ehrenpräsident ist der Istanbuler Bürgermeister. Es ist ein Verein, der aus dem Nichts gestampft wurde. Es gab den schon mal, da hieß er anders, da hieß er, ich sag's jetzt mal, Istanbul Bürgermeister Belediyaspor. Das hast du jetzt super verstanden wahrscheinlich.
Googlen könnte ich es noch nicht.
Ja, also es ist tatsächlich, also heißt übersetzt der Istanbuler Großstadtverwaltungsverein mehr oder weniger.
Okay, warum braucht die Großstadtverwaltung ein Verein?
Das ist die große Frage der Türkei, die sich alle stellen. Wieso? Vor allem, also es ist immer das gleiche, sobald Bajaj Scheren, das ist letztes Jahr viel passiert, einer der Großen besiegt, dann kommt die Frage, ich fahre mit dem Bus und werde dann besiegt mit dem Geld, das ich für den Bus investiert habe oder keine Ahnung, den ich für irgendwie eine Steuer investiert habe. Also der Verein ist extrem unbeliebt bei den anderen, klar, nicht nur weil er erfolgreich ist, sondern eben weil er einfach aus dem Nichts gestampft wurde.
Wann war das?
Das ist schon vor Ewigkeiten passiert. 2014 gab es dann schon eher so eine Marketing-Maßnahme, dass der Verein nicht mehr so lang hieß, sondern Basaksehri hieß. Basaksehri ist ein neuer Stadtteil von Istanbul, hat dann neue Farben, neues Logo, ein Stadion bekommen, auch ein kleines, aber wie gesagt, Fans, die, die da sind, sind auch mehr oder weniger, glaube ich, gekauft, muss ich mal fast sagen. Das sind so Studenten, die ein paar ganz hübsche Sachen bekommen und dann den Verein anfallen, aber man hört es nicht wirklich. Also vergangenes Wochenende war Basaksehir gegen Galatasaray und man hat natürlich beim Torjubel von Basaksehir keine Fans gehört. Aber die Mannschaft, der Trainer ist für mich der Star, auch wenn jetzt mit Adebayor zum Beispiel ein Spiel auch da spielt, der recht bekannt ist mit Elia, jemand da ist, Ada Turan ist dort. Aber der Star ist für mich der Trainer, der die Mannschaft in den letzten Jahren aufgebaut hat. Ja, eine gute Idee hat, die man in den Türkei-Spielen gewinnen kann und nicht mit einer guten Defensive. Das vergessen die Großen immer, die vermeiden nicht Großen inzwischen, wenn man auf die Tabelle guckt. Aber man muss so, es hat auch viel Wahlgeschmack. Also wie gesagt, es ist keine Fans, der Verein wird auch mehr oder weniger unterstützt vom Start. Wenn man in das Klubgelände kommt, und das ist übrigens ein sehr hübsches Klubgelände, ich war da schon ein paar Mal, wirst du von einem großen Atatürk-Soldaten, auch von einem großen Erdogan-Poster begrüßt. Er war auch der erste, der in diesem Stadion ein Tor geschossen hat damals, hat Fettkrieg gemacht.
Das habe ich mitbekommen. Genau. Ach, das war Basakci.
Genau, richtig. Deswegen ist die Beliebtheit hältsichen Grenzen und die Mannschaft ist auch relativ alt. Man hat auch in den letzten…
Ich meine sogar Eltero Elia, ich habe gerade noch mal nachgeguckt, 31 Jahre Zwischenzeit.
Er macht wirklich einen guten Job. Also ich kann da nicht wirklich viel Negatives sagen. Aber man munkelt, dass der Verein, also man checkt in den letzten Jahren auch sehr, sehr viel Europaleague oder Champions League auch alles ab, auch Pokal checkt man ab, um sich komplett auf die Liga zu konzentrieren. Also die komplette Konzentration geht dahin, Meister zu werden und man munkelt in der Türkei danach den Club zu verkaufen an irgendeinen östlichen Investoren, der Bock auf die Superliga hat.
Verrückt. Ja, Wahnsinn, was man alles nicht mitbekommen kann. Und jetzt haben wir gelernt, ok, also der Trainer ist ein guter. Wir wissen jetzt ein bisschen was über die Hintergründe des Vereins. Mannschaft relativ alt, sieht man eben auch an den von dir genannten, also Turan, Elia, das ist schon jenseits der 30, Adebayo ja auch inzwischen schon 34. Und jetzt hast du mir ja aber eingangs schon gesagt, Herbstmeister ist jetzt keine Neuigkeit. Was lief denn in den letzten Spielzeiten dann immer falsch, dass das nicht zum Meistertitel gereicht hat?
Ich glaube dann tatsächlich die Erfahrung im Titelkampf dann. Vielleicht sogar auch ein bisschen auch vom Trainer, also der das alles sehr, sehr gut gemacht hat. Man muss auch dazu sagen, letztes Jahr, wenn es eigentlich so wäre gewesen, haben sie wirklich riesen Pech gehabt. Da haben sie im Heimspiel gegen Sivaspor, das sie hätten gewinnen müssen, wenn sie das gewonnen hätten, wäre es auch vom Restprogramm her, hätten sie es auch dann eigentlich gepackt. In der Nachspielzeit greift der Toiter daneben, was er der ganze Saison nicht gemacht hat. Er hat eine überragende Saison gespielt, Volkan Babacan. Jetzt glaube ich auch deswegen, sie spielt nicht mehr dieses Jahr, sie sitzt an der Mert Gynok. Der hat letztes Jahr die Meisterschaft gekostet. Aber es ist schon so ein bisschen, dass man dann an dem Punkt, wo es dann ernst wird, und dann kommen eben mit Galatasaray, mit Besiktas Vereine einfach, die dann die Spieler hatten oder haben, die, wenn es drauf ankommt und die Meisterschaft geht, dann vielleicht den Punkt Erfahrung mehr haben, dann da eine Serie starten, wenn es sein muss. Und daran ist es immer wieder gescheiter, wenn ich sage, letztes Jahr war es großes Pech eigentlich. Also hätten sie gegen Sivas, aber was eben auch vielleicht Erfahrung ist. Also die haben da nur 1-0 geführt, hätten nachlegen müssen, dann haben sie ein bisschen Muffensausen bekommen. Ich glaube auch, dass letztes Jahr Araturan die Meisterschaft versammelt hat. Den mussten sie mehr oder weniger holen von Barcelona. Bis er kam, hat dieses System zugebracht.
Warum mussten sie den mehr oder weniger holen?
Ja, da muss ich, also da brauchen wir glaube ich 5 Top Kurzpass, um das zu erklären. Araturan hat auch eine gewisse Verbindung, Nähe zu gewissen Personen in der Türkei. Der Verein hat das auch. Der Präsident steht dem Araturan sehr nahe. Bei Barcelona hat das nicht mehr hingehauen. Also der war außen vor, hat keinen Verein gefunden, wollte auch glaube ich nach China, aber selbst in China hat man erkannt, dass der Araturan nicht mehr wirklich geradeaus laufen kann. Irgendwann wurde mehr oder weniger Araturan auferlegt, dass man ihn holen muss. Der Verein hat bis dahin Herbstmeisterschaft wunderbar gespielt und dann musste man Araturan integrieren. Aber seine körperliche Verfassung hat niemals gereicht, um in dieser Mannschaft zu spielen. Dann saß zum Beispiel auch ein Elia draußen oder ein Mostoro, der mir sehr gut gefällt ist, der Kopf dieser Mannschaft, ein Brasilianer, auch ein bisschen älter, aber ein guter Mann. Der saß dann auch mal draußen und Araturan spielen musste. Ich glaube auch, das war ein Grund, warum es nicht geschafft wird. Dieses Jahr spielen Araturan selbst und sie haben einen großen Vorsprung.
Okay, und mit Nähe zu gewissen Personen meinst du vermutlich politische Personen.
Ja, genau.
Über die wir eventuell –ist der Name in diesem Podcast auch schon gefallen –also überragende Defensive 7 Gegentore. Nur um das in den Kontext zu rücken, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, die zweitbeste Defensive stellt dann Tabellen 2 mit 15 Toren. Das heißt, weniger als die Hälfte hat da Bashak Shia bisher kassiert. Und jetzt würde man ja auf Tabellenplatz 2, 3, 4 die üblichen Verdächtigen erwarten. Und jetzt hoffentlich sagst du mir jetzt nicht gleich, dass die auch schon die ganze Zeit da oben sind, schon seit Jahren. Und ich wusste es bloß mal wieder nicht. Aber Yeni Malatyaspor liegt auf Tabellenplatz 2.
Wer? Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass ich in der Türkei auch vielen erklären muss. Also das ist für viele eine Überraschung. Also für mich ist das die Überraschung. Nicht Basakşehir, oder nicht jemand anderes, sondern Yeni Malatyaspor ist... Yeni heißt übrigens neu, der Verein. Also Malatyaspor selbst war der große Traditionsfeind in der Region, ist aber pleite gegangen.
Welche Region ist das in der Region?
Das geht Richtung Südostanatolien an der Grenze zu Zentral-Südosten. Er hat pleite gemacht, wurde dann neu gegründet, und dann über die Jahre mit Leuten, die dann vernünftig gewirtschaftet haben, sind sie nach Omo gekommen. Sehr, sehr überraschend, dass der Trainer, der langjährige Co-Trainer von Abdülaz Özil, der Trainer von Basakşehir ist, und auch in Deutschland kann man ihn bekennen, ist nämlich Errol Bullut, der das Fußball spielen in Frankfurt gelernt hat, macht einen überragenden Job. Also die Mannschaft ist jetzt nicht qualitativ auf dem höchsten Niveau, würde ich nicht behaupten, aber hat auch Hand und Fuß, was die Art und Weise, wie sie spielen, auch eher defensiv veranlagt. Auch erfahrene Spieler, auch nicht wirklich die jüngste Mannschaft, aber haben sich das tatsächlich erarbeitet. Also Errol Bullut, ich kenne seine Leute auch, ich habe immer wieder mal Kontakt, akribische Arbeiter, der auch bei den Basakşehir schon sehr, sehr viel investiert hat, dass Basakşehir auf dem Punkt ist, vor allem was Gegner-Scouting angeht, was Analyse angeht, was in der Türkei leider immer noch sehr, sehr stiefmütterlich behandelt wird, gerade bei den Großen. Aber die Vereine, die es ernst genommen haben, stehen jetzt auf Platz eins und zwei. Das ist für mich eigentlich schon dann auch wieder der Lohn dafür, dass man gewisse Sachen richtig macht. Ja, kann man nur Kompliment sagen. Malatyaspor schaut jetzt nicht immer gut aus, aber es ist super verdient, dass sie da oben stehen. Und es freut mich auch.
Und jetzt haben wir ja in der Türkei immer schon das Thema gehabt, die Stadtvereine, also die aus Istanbul kommen, und die in Anführungszeichen Landvereine, die aus irgendwelchen Regionen kommen. Ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass Bursaspor einer der ersten war, der dann auch, glaube ich, Meister geworden ist.
Genau, Trabzon und dann Bursa.
Genau, Trabzon und Bursa, genau. Und Bursa hat aber ja, glaube ich, auch eine Verbindung zu Erdogan, wenn ich… Nee, verwechsel ich gerade mit irgendwas. Und jetzt Malatyaspor. Was hat das eine Bedeutung für die Liga? Wie wird in der Türkei damit umgegangen? Spricht das dafür, dass sich jetzt die Regionen, die sich immer so ein bisschen vernachlässigt gefühlt haben, im sportlichen Bereich, vielleicht auch politisch, das kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen, dass die mit guter Arbeit da reinstoßen? Oder ist das jetzt eine Momentaufnahme und hat auch damit zu tun, dass wir dann später drüber sprechen werden, dass Fener gerade auf einem Abstiegsplatz liegt?
Ich sehe das nicht als Momentaufnahme. Es hat sich einfach jetzt entwickelt. Wie gesagt, ich habe gerade das Thema Gegner-Scouting angesprochen. Das ist nur ein Aspekt. Aber die Vereine haben in den letzten Jahren an allen Fronten, da wo man es kann, haben sie sich versucht zu entwickeln. Das ist auch die Infrastruktur. Dass man überhaupt einen Scouting hat, also nicht nur einen Gegner-Scouting, sondern überhaupt einen Scouting. Dass man nicht nur über YouTube nach irgendwelchen Neuzugängen sucht oder weil der Onkel gerade in Lille wohnt und da ein Spiel erkennt, sondern nicht, dass man dann auch selbst Scouting gemacht hat, das mit Infrastructure, dass man Ernährungsbreite eingestellt hat, dass man Physiotherapeuten eingestellt hat, dass man Techniktrainer eingestellt hat, dass man überhaupt Kabinen hatte. Das ist wirklich tatsächlich –das war und ist auch bei –wir kommen da gleich auch zu einem Verein, der gar nichts davon hat zum Beispiel. Also das passiert auch, aber das hat sich alles in den letzten Entwicklungen, das sind auch alles hochmoderne Anlagen. Also als ich bei Basaksehir war vor zwei, drei Jahren, da war ich für Spox noch aktiv, da habe ich ein Interview geführt. Mich hat die Sprache verschlagen, was das für eine Anlage ist. Ich wurde auch ein bisschen rumgeführt in diesen Analyse-Räumen, die sind wirklich hoch technologisiert und die Plätze 1, 2, 3 super. Also irgendwann war mir schon klar, dass die erfolgreich werden. Das hat sich dann auch bewahrheitet.
Und woher haben die das Geld?
In der Türkei gibt es wirklich hohe TV-Gelder. Also ich würde es nicht sagen, auf dem Bundesliga-Evo, aber sehr, sehr nahe zum Bundesliga-Evo, auch die Punkte-Premien, die Sieg-Premien sind sehr, sehr hoch. Das Sponsoring von der staatlichen Notarie ist sehr, sehr hoch. Und die Vereine haben irgendwann gecheckt, wo man das Geld investieren muss.
Nicht in Gehälter, sondern in Infrastruktur.
Genau, und es bringt was. Auch wenn ich jetzt an die Stadien denke, es waren früher so viele Bruchbuden. Und jetzt steht fast in jedem Superligstad ein überragendes Stadion. Jetzt wenn man an die Bewerbung Türkei für die Euro 2024 denkt, die haben sich jetzt schon ein paar Mal beworben in der Türkei. Früher hat man bei diesen Präsentationen immer Projekte gezeigt. Also die Projekte, die man bauen will. Diesmal hat man fertige Stadionen einfach auch gezeigt.
Ja, das ist mir auch aufgefallen.
Also da waren wirklich, also nur in Ankara in der Hauptstadt, da fehlt noch ein Stadion, das wird jetzt auch schon gerade gebaut. Aber in allen, wirklich in den wichtigsten Städten, auch zum Beispiel Sivaspor zum Beispiel, da kommen wir gleich noch hin, das war früher ein Horror für die Auswärtsmannschaften, da im Winter hinzufahren, wenn man auf Eisplatten gespielt hat, jetzt steht da eine hochmoderne Arena mit einer super Rasenheizung und jeder spielt da gerne zum Beispiel. Das ist jetzt für die Heimmannschaft manchmal nicht so funktionsvoll, weil das früher dann auch ein Gimmick für sie war, aber es hebt natürlich dann das Niveau an, wenn die Vereine anfangen, schlau zu wirtschaften und das Geld richtig zu investieren. Und eben dann auch im Fall von Indy Malatya-Spor zum Beispiel, auch den Mut zu haben, dann einem Typen wie Errol Bullard auch mal die Chance zu geben, dass der seine Idee einbringen kann und nicht ein älterer Trainer, der einfach nur ein gutes Verhältnis zum Präsidenten hat.
Ja, man bekommt so einen leichten Eindruck. Das ist ja alles sehr, sehr interessant. Und damit kommen wir auch so ein bisschen zu der Verlangs der Verfolger. Also mit acht Punkten Rückstand auf den aktuellen Tabellen ersten liegen Besiktas, Trabzon-Spor, Galatasaray, Kasimpasa, Istanbul und Antalya-Spor. Die alle haben acht Punkte Rückstand. Da geht es ja nur ums Torverhältnis, wer da jetzt gerade wo liegt. Erzähl mir mal, was ist da bei diesen Vereinen nennenswert zu wissen? Gibt es da jemanden, den du herausheben würdest?
Also Kasimpasa ist sehr interessant, war bis zu dem letzten Spieltag auch auf Platz zwei. Es gab sogar News, die es sogar in den deutschen Agenturen geschafft hat. Der Verein hat nach dem wirklich sehr, sehr starken Saisonstart bis Platz zwei, bis zum 15. Spieltag alle Verträge bis 2021 verlängert. Also Spieler und Trainer einfach alle durch.
Wie man immer so sagt, im Erfolg trifft man die besten Entscheidungen.
Genau, einen Spieltag später sind sie auf Platz sechs, sieben abgerutscht. Nee, Istanbuler Verein, der Verein von Recep Tayyip Erdogan auch. Also jetzt nicht den er irgendwie aus dem Ding gestellt ist, er kommt aus der Ecke, also aus dem Stadtteil. Da ist er um die Ecke geboren, hat auch da selbst gekickt. Der Stadion ist auch nach seinem Namen benannt. Ist wirklich mitten in Istanbul. Manchmal ist es verblüffend, wenn man da vorbeifährt, da fährt man vom Taxi-Platz runter Richtung Meer und dann auf einmal steht da mitten in irgendwelchen Zwischenhäusern ein Stadion. Also das ist schon irgendwie geil. Hat auch nicht so viel. Dahinter eigentlich ein großer Geldgeber, der vor ein paar Jahren ein bisschen mehr Bock hatte, Geld zu investieren. Hat dann auch damals so Leute wie Rein Babel, Andreas Isaksson und so weiter geholt, Adrian Deryok, und irgendwann hat er gesagt, boah, irgendwie wird es hier nicht so richtig. Hat dann so einen Salary Cap eingeführt, 300.000 Euro darf der Spitzenverdiener verdienen. Hat man aber dann vielleicht auch Standortvorteil Istanbul, ein paar Leute geholt, die vielleicht, wenn jetzt woanders ein bisschen mehr Geld verdienen können, also ich gehe meistens zum türkischen Spieler, aber die dann halt einfach in Istanbul dann leben wollten und dann halt in Kasim Pasha spielen, wo der Druck dann auch jetzt vielleicht nicht so groß ist. Und jetzt während der Saison mit Mustafa Denizli eine Trainer-Ikone geholt, der mit Fener, mit Besiktas, mit Galatasaray jeweils Meister geworden ist in seiner langen Trainer-Karriere, auch die Liga immer noch sehr, sehr gut kennt und mit dem ging es dann auch mal aufwärts. Ich glaube aber, dass die Kategorität nicht reichen wird, da dauerhaft dann irgendwie oben zu spielen. Zumal tatsächlich Denizli selbst gesagt hat, wenn sie bis zum 28. Spieltag 3 Punkte Rückstand haben, werden sie Meister. Das ist ein bisschen, glaube ich, übertrieben. Ganz interessant ist aber natürlich die Rolle von Besiktas und Galatasaray. Besiktas hat letztes Jahr gegen Bayern gespielt in der Champions League. Eine überragende Champions-League-Saison auch gespielt. In der Gruppenphase kein Spiel verloren. Und jetzt sind sie in der Europa League sogar gescheitert. In einer Gruppe mit Habsburg, Malmö und Genk sind sie die Letzter geworden. Das ist eigentlich Wahnsinn. Das ist auch völlig verdient. Ich habe fast alle Spiele gesehen. Gegen Malmö haben sie in beiden Spielen keine zwei Torschüsse aufs Tor gebracht. Malmö hat mit Markus Rosenberger übrigens vorne drin. Ja, einen ganz tollen Ball gespielt. Besiktas hat eigentlich schon seit Jahren viele Schulden. Hat man aber dann in diesem sportlichen Aufstieg das Risiko gewagt, noch mehr zu investieren, noch mehr teure Spieler zu holen, um vielleicht auch Galafena noch weiter fernzuhalten? Weil man war schon viele Jahre das dritte Glied einfach und in dieser Rolle hat man sich nicht wohlgefühlt. Zumindest die Vereinsoberen, den Fans, das ist glaube ich nicht so wichtig gewesen, gerade die, die auf sehr treuen Stadion gehen. Aber man hat sich übernommen tatsächlich. Also jetzt ganz frisch muss jetzt der Vertrag mit Pepe aufgelöst werden, damit er einfach nicht mehr bezahlen konnte. Also das –und mit Negredo ging auch jetzt ein Spieler während der Saison, obwohl er gar nicht weg wollte, musste er auch gehen, weil man sein Gehalt nicht bezahlen konnte. Man hat sich komplett übernommen. Und die Mannschaft ist alt. Auch da gibt es das Problem, man muss jetzt einen Umbruch einleiten. Aber jetzt kommen wir zum großen Problem dieser drei Großen. Das ist das Financial Fairplay. Und Galatasaray, Besiktas, Fenerbahce unterlegen alle strengsten Auflagen von Financial Fairplay. Man darf nur das ausgeben, was man einnimmt, bei Spielerverkäufen und Einkäufen. Und so viele Spieler gibt es jetzt nicht, die man verkaufen kann. Und wenn man jetzt das große Bild nehmen will, warum sind Galafener, also Bratfener, soweit unten, aber Besiktas im Vergleich zu den anderen so durchgereicht worden? Ich glaube, das ist ein großes Thema, weil man einfach, früher hat man einfach blind investieren können. Also irgendwann hat dann der, wenn man sonst zu viel gemacht hat, hat dann irgendein treuer Sponsor oder was auch immer dann nochmal 50 Millionen reingeschustert oder der Verein hat irgendwie die Steuern erlassen. Das geht jetzt einfach nicht mehr. Also man hat nicht mehr diesen großen Vorsprung zu den anderen, dass man jetzt dann einfach sagt, okay, jetzt haben wir eine scheiß Vorrunde gespielt. Jetzt hole ich dann einfach nochmal Van Persie und Snyder und wie sie alle heißen. Das ist jetzt einfach nicht mehr drin. Und dann kommen die, ja, wie soll man sagen, dass der Vorsprung dann doch nicht so groß ist. Das erkennt man dann einfach daran. Und dieses Financial Fairplay hat eigentlich das gezeigt, was man eigentlich seit Jahren vermutet hat, dass die Vereine nur durch irgendwelche Geldzuschussereien sich einen Vorteil verschafft haben. Und jetzt da, wo sie wirklich wirtschaften müssen, klug handeln müssen, nicht klug handeln können, weil sie Leute dazu nicht haben.
Und das Financial Fairplay betrifft alle drei. Also Gala, Besiktas und Fener.
Genau. Also Pandra auch. Aber für diese ist es jetzt vielleicht nicht so wichtig. Aber für diese drei, die dann auch Anspruch haben, auch international Erfolg zu haben, trifft das ganz heftig. Gerade bei Besiktas, wenn man bedenkt, welche Spieler man geholt hat, mit Gerry Medell, mit Pepe, mit Negredo. Wenn du dann irgendwann mal daneben langst, bei so einem teuren Spieler, und das nicht mehr korrigieren kannst, hat das sehr, sehr schwere Folgen. Gerade die drei großen, mit Besiktas, mit Galatasaray, mit Fenerbahce, die haben alle drei keinen Top-Stürmer. Alle drei nicht. Galatasaray musste vor der Saison Waffe Timbi Gommis abgeben, für 6 Millionen Euro für einen Spieler, der letztes Jahr 30 Ligatore geschossen hat. Den konnten sie nicht ersetzen. Erhan Deryog ist übrig geliehen, aber der ist öfter verletzt, als er atmet. Und Besiktas musste Negredo abgeben, Fenerbahce hat mit Slimani an den Stürmer ausgeliehen, der in der Wette noch auf der Bank saß. Wenn du anfällig hitten bist, weil du hinten kein Spiel hast und vorne dann nicht triffst, dann stehst du da, wo du bist.
Und du hast einen alten Kader und hast jetzt die Auflage, du darfst nur noch einen ausgeben, was du eingenommen hast.
Genau. Gerade bei Besiktas zum Beispiel, Vertrag mit PP aufgelöst, Vertrag mit Negredo aufgelöst. Gut, da gab es auch ein bisschen Ablöse, aber nicht so, dass du so einen tollen Nachfolger fitten kannst. Du hast dann mit Adam Light zum Beispiel einen guten Spieler ausgeliehen, aber auch nur ausgeliehen. Das ist dann auch eine Frage, ob du den dann auch behalten darfst. So diese Zirkulation zu gewährleisten, da fehlen einfach dann die Spieler, die du verkaufen kannst. Bei Fenerbahce war es vor der Saison so, dass man mit Giuliano und Josef de Sosa zwei Spiele abgeben konnte zum Beispiel, die relativ viel Geld eingebracht haben, aber das waren einfach die beiden wichtigsten Spieler von Fenerbahce. Und da hat der Philipp Koki gesagt, bitte nicht verkaufen. Das sind meine wichtigen Spieler und die haben sie verkauft und die dann dafür geholt worden sind. Sorry, Super League ist jetzt keine Premier League, aber selbst für die Super League reichen diese Spieler nicht. Aber jetzt haben sie das Problem, dass sie…
Wie ist das mit Jugendspielern? Müssten gerade nicht diese etablierten Vereine auch ganz gute Jugendausbildungszentren haben, weil es ja relativ attraktiv ist, bei den drei zu spielen, weil man irgendwann vielleicht mal Champions League spielen kann?
Da fehlt einfach der Mut. Besiktas hat jetzt mit Güvern Yalçin vorne einen Stürmer, der kommt aus Deutschland, 19 Jahre alt. Er hat durchaus Talent, aber noch lange nicht das Zeug dauerhaft, Stürmer Nr. 1 bei Besiktas zu werden. Aber das ist ein Spieler, der jetzt nicht von unten ausgebildet wurde, sondern eben, ich glaube, Leverkusen wurde der für 250.000 Euro geholt. Galatasaray hat eine sehr interessante Jugendmannschaft, jetzt auch ein Pokal letzte Woche. Die Türkei ist ja ein Pokal, immer so ein langes Ding, mit Hin- und Drückspiel in der ersten Runde und dann Gruppenphase. Da hat man sich getraut, mal ein Pokal gegen einen Zweitligisten, Rittligisten, mal fünf, sechs junge Spieler aufs Feld zu schicken. Und die haben das wirklich super gemacht. Und im nächsten Spiel waren die alle nicht mehr dabei. Also da fehlt dann einfach der Mut, auch von Fahri Terim zum Beispiel, den ich sehr, sehr schätze, und der das ja immer wieder auch gemacht hat. Jetzt auch in der Saison, Gallas Stammverteidiger ist ein 18-jähriger Osam Kabak. Macht noch viele Fehler, aber ist okay. Also besser als ein Spieler, der 400 Millionen verdient und die gleichen Fehler macht. Aber dann fehlt halt der Mut, an den zweiten einen vielleicht auch zu investieren. Also in der Türkei kommt immer wieder dieses Beispiel VfB Stuttgart vor Jahren, als die auch klam waren und dann diese ganzen jungen Wilden hochgebracht haben. Es kommt immer wieder dieses Beispiel. Aber da fehlt einfach mit der Türkei…
Sehr interessant, das hätte ich ja nicht mal in Deutschland als Beispiel gebracht.
Aber selbst bei so großen Vereinen, bei so großen Namen, fehlt der Mut zu sagen, ich probiere es jetzt einfach mal. Trabzinsport macht das gerade vor. Da spielen gerade tatsächlich vier, fünf Jungs, auch da mit Einwechslung an 5 und 6, die die Mannschaft deutlich weiter unten und jetzt nach oben gespult haben. Tatsächlich ist es so, dass ich gerade Trabzinsport, das ist die Mannschaft, die ich am seltensten verpassen will in der Süperliga. Ich gucke die sehr, sehr gerne. Die spielen sehr, sehr interessanten Fußball. Der Torwart ist ein richtig guter, auch wenn er noch Fehler macht, mit Yusuf Yazidi, Abdulkar Di Ömer und so weiter und so fort. Wirklich, wirklich gute Jungs. Und die haben sich getraut, die Jungs hochzuziehen. Ich glaube, das ist ein Beispiel für viele andere auch. Jetzt auch im Pokal, zum Beispiel Fenerbahce, letzte Woche gegen einen Zweite-Gesten, der in der Zweitliga auf Platz 18 ist, hat sich der Trainer nicht getraut, mehr als zwei junge Spieler aufs Feld zu bringen.
Die stehen natürlich auch schon so tief unten drin, dass bei denen der Griff der zweiten Liga schon so fest ist, dass einem dann ein bisschen die Luft zum Mut haben fehlt. Aber die Frage, die ich mir dann stelle, wenn Financial Fairplay sich innerhalb der Liga so krass auswirkt, ist ja interessant, dass wir das zwar europäisch jetzt schon so über Bande mitbekommen haben bei Besiktas, aber in der Liga sind die Auswirkungen ja noch viel, viel krasser offenbar. Wie wurde das denn dann aufgenommen, dass wir durch die Football-Leaks-Enthüllung wissen, dass sowohl PSG als auch Manchester City sich in Zusammenarbeit mit Gianni Infantino aus dem Fairplay so ein bisschen raus debattiert haben?
Also wir Türken –und ich sage das absichtlich, wir Türken, damit dann irgendwelche türkischen Hörer nicht sagen, was willst du denn zu vorwerfen? Deswegen sage ich es absichtlich, wir Türken haben ja so einen kleinen Minderwertigkeitskomplex. Die wollen uns ja eh nicht dienwesten und die wollen ja eh, dass wir keinen Erfolg haben und so weiter. Natürlich kam dann genau dieses Gerede dann wieder hoch. Also, schau, was das ist.
Ganz von der Hand zu weisen ist es ja nicht. Also nicht jetzt zu sagen, dass die Türkei weniger bedeutsam wäre, aber zumindest war sie für Gianni Infantino nicht so wichtig, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, vermutlich sehr, sehr viel mit Geld zusammenhängt. Aber das ist ja eigentlich der Wahnsinn. Wo ist der große, also ganz großen Aufschrei?
Das ist sicher richtig, aber es verändert nicht die Tatsache, dass die türkischen Vereine einfach schlecht wirtschaften. Und dann sowieso, es ist ja nicht so, dass gerade diese Auflagen, die jetzt gerade den Vereinen gegeben wurden, die kamen nicht auf einmal. Also es gab immer wieder mal eine gelbe Karte, dann war es mal eine hellgelbe Karte davor. Aber wenn jetzt diesmal nicht macht, dann, also da gab es schon sehr, sehr viel Anlauf. Also ich glaube, es ist richtig, dass da mit zweierlei Maß gemessen wurde. Und es ist ja nicht nur in Türkei, es ist ja auch glaube ich mit Sion, auch in der Schweiz, wenig passiert. Das macht alles richtig sein und ist auch alles richtig. Aber letztlich ist es immer noch so, dass die Vereine schlecht wirtschaften, mehrmals darauf hingewiesen wurden, das richtig zu machen. Normalerweise, Galatasaray zum Beispiel, müsste ja jetzt normalerweise ausgeschlossen worden sein, weil man zwei, drei Mal irgendwelche Auflagen gegen Auflagen verstoßen hat. Und dann hat man gesagt, okay, Uefa, jetzt geben wir noch eine Chance. Wir machen jetzt mit euch einen Vierjahresvertrag. Es wurde wirklich ein Vertrag geschlossen mit der Uefa. Ihr müsst vier Jahre lang –das waren, glaube ich, so acht, neun Punkte, die Gala einhalten muss, um nicht dauerhaft aus dem Europapokal ausgeschlossen zu werden. Die Auflagen sind wirklich heavy für den Club. Eigentlich auch nicht wirklich zu erfüllen. Aber wie gesagt, da kann sich Gala nicht beschweren, warum die Uefa das macht, wenn man vorher schon mehrmals darauf hingewiesen wurde, was man richtig machen muss. Und die Auflagen vorher waren jetzt nicht so schwierig wie jetzt. Und Gala macht jetzt schon wieder den Fehler, dass man sagt, wir sind jetzt auf Platz fünf und in der Europa League lief es auch nicht, der Champions League ist auch nicht richtig gut. Vielleicht versuchen wir dann doch, irgendwie was zu machen. Also bei Fenerbahce zum Beispiel. Ganz aktuell hat der Präsident gerade gesagt, vielleicht verzichten wir einfach auf den Europapokal und missachten jetzt die Regeln und nehmen sie in Kauf, jetzt mehrere Jahre nicht im Europapokal teilzunehmen, um einfach unsere Mannschaft dann nach vorne zu bringen. Also man versteht einfach die Signale nicht.
Das ist natürlich –sprich, das Glashaus ist ein so großes, dass man Angst hat, dass der Stein nicht mal mehr aus dem Haus rauskommt. So ist es. Andererseits ist es trotzdem natürlich –der Fakt ist schon trotzdem krass, dass der Fairplay-Teil vom Financial Fairplay ein Witz ist. Und dann halt manche Vereine so deutlich trifft. Dann lass mal jetzt über Fener sprechen. Das ist ja wirklich krass. Tabellenplatz 17, das heißt aktuell auf dem Abstiegsrang. Er ist dreimal gewonnen nach 16 Spielen, 16 Tore geschossen, 24 kassiert. Wie kritisch ist die Situation da? Die Tabelle sieht sehr kritisch aus.
Ganz schwieriger Fall, Fenerbahce. Ich komme jetzt vom aktuellen Mal zurück. Am Montagabend hat Fenerbahce zu Hause gegen Erzurum Spor gespielt. Erzurum Spor ist ein Aufsteiger, der, glaube ich, punktgleich mit Fener, also Fener 17. Erzurum ist 16. Hat den kleinsten Etat in der Liga. Er ist auch im Nordosten, kältester Stadt der Türkei, ganz schräger Standardvorteil. Aber für Fenerbahce in dem Augenblick der beste Gegner, weil Fenerbahce einen Trainer bekommen hat mit Arshin Janal, den die Fans seit einem Jahr herbrüllen. Nach jedem Spiel, gerade in der Saison, wo man wirklich selten gewonnen hat, hat man den Namen Arshin Janal gefordert, weil er der letzte Meistertrainer von Fenerbahce ist, nach dem Disput mit dem Präsidenten den Verein verlassen hat. Und jetzt kam der.
Also jetzt auch wirklich 14.12.
Genau, ganz frisch. Das erste Spiel am Montag gegen Erdrumsburg, 2-0 geführt, auch zu Hause. Alle haben von Fenerbahce gesprochen. Und am Ende stand es 2-2. Lennarty hat das Tor gemacht in der 90. Minute, sein erstes Tor in der Super League. Ach, verrückt, Lennarty.
Zu Hause oder auswärts?
Zu Hause, vor fast voller Hütte auch. Es gab schon tatsächlich auch eine Aufbruchsstimmung. Und Arsenal ist auch schon der zweite Name, den man gefordert hat. Weil davor, 19 Jahre lang, war Azizilde den Präsident bei Fenerbahce, hat den Verein fast schon autoritär geführt, wurde dann bei der Präsidentenwahl im Sommer mit großem Abstand abgewählt. Ali Koç kam, Ali Koç ist einer der reichsten Männer der Türkei, in großer Fenerbahce Fan, noch relativ jung, hat sehr viel Geld investiert, aber auch sehr viele Fehler gemacht schon am Anfang. Beide Hoffnungsträger, bei Arsenal muss man noch abwarten, Ali Koç, der große Hoffnungsträger, hat in dem ersten halben Jahr noch nicht diese Aufruchsstimmung erzeugen können bzw. sich nicht lange aufrechterhalten können. Jetzt kommt mit Arsenal der sportliche Hoffnungsträger und man hat dann auch einfach gesehen, auch der kann nicht zaubern, weil die Mannschaft einfach so schlecht ist. Man muss es wirklich sagen.
Wer stellt denn die Mannschaften zusammen bei so einem Verein wie Fenerbahce? Gibt es da Sportdirektoren?
Macht das der Trainer? Ali Koç kam jetzt mit Komoli, ein französischer Sportdirektor, der vorher mal Kalaplaner bei diversen Stationen in Frankreich und England war. Das ist jetzt keine so große Nummer. Ist auch umstritten in der Türkei, was ich auch verstehe, weil letztlich natürlich muss Fenerbahce sich international ausrichten. Aber erst mal muss man die Hausaufgaben in der Türkei machen. Ich glaube, dass es nichts hilft, jemanden als Sportdirektor zu investieren, der den Kalaplanen soll, der die türkische Liga nicht kennt. Die türkische Liga ist jetzt, wie gesagt, keine Premier League, aber es ist eine schon komplexe Liga. Es ist keine einfache Liga. Sie hat ihre Bedingungen, um dort zu spielen. Man muss schon gewisse Kriterien erfüllen, auch was den Kala angeht. Auch inzwischen bei sehr, sehr schwierigen Auswärtsspielen. Es ist längst nicht so, dass die großen Galafenas, Besiktas, einfach jedes Auswärtsspiel in einem Spiel gewinnen. Selbst die Heimspiele sind längst kein No-Brander mehr. Und dann jemanden, den Kala zusammenstellen zu lassen, der sich da überhaupt nicht auskennt, ist einfach fatal. Und daran sind schon andere gescheitert. Da ist auch schon Fener schon mal dran gescheitert. Man hat schon damals mit Terraneo einen Italiener geholt, der die Liga auch nicht gekannt hat und einfach irgendwie Kontakte hatte, dann Nani geholt hat, Van Persie geholt hat, obwohl der Gesundheitscheck durchgefallen ist, hat man trotzdem durchgewogen und so weiter. Und ja, der Kader ist jetzt einfach selbst für die Liga zu schlecht. Und das große Problem ist, dass man der Türkei davon ausgeht, bei Fenerbahce davon ausgeht, ach, die werden doch nicht absteigen. Die werden doch nicht absteigen, die sind doch viel zu gut.
Der Klassiker, ja.
Aber sie sind nicht viel zu gut, weil die anderen, man sieht es an der Tabellenspitze, man sieht es aber auch unten, die haben einfach ausgewogenere Kader. Selbst Risespor auf Platz 18, die übrigens Fenerbahce dran geschlagen haben vor ein paar Wochen.
Der einzige Sieg war das von denen, ja.
Und selbst sie hatten tatsächlich sehr, sehr viel Pech in den letzten Wochen, haben aber für mich einen ausgewogenen Kader, keinen besseren aber einen ausgewogenen Kader als Fenerbahce. Sie haben vorne einen Stürmer, den sie auch einwechseln können, den hat Fenerbahce jetzt nicht zum Beispiel. Und da habe ich schon die Befürchtung, dass es für Fenerbahce schon lange dauern wird, um sich da unten rauszuboxen, wenn sie es überhaupt schaffen. Also ich habe so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, dass man das nicht erkennt, dass der Kader so schwach ist. Wie gesagt, jetzt mit Arsenal ist schon ein Trainer gekommen, der weiß, wie man so eine Feinheit Türkei führen muss, auch in der Mannschaft. Aber das Problem ist, dass er seine letzte Mannschaft hatte, die war einfach deutlich, deutlich besser. Also er hatte einen Raul Meireles im Mittelfeld, der noch Topfit war. Er hat mit Musa Saouf einen Stürmer, den er getroffen hat und so weiter. Und die Mannschaft jetzt hat weder die Qualität und ich glaube auch noch den Charakter. Also es ist nicht Charakterschwäche, sondern da fehlt einfach auch ein Typ, der diese Mannschaft dann auch mitführen kann, weil er selbst so unumstritten ist. Es gibt keinen Spieler, der spielen muss in dieser Mannschaft.
Ja, gut, ein Abstiegskampf ist halt auch wirklich nochmal was anderes. Das sieht man in allen Ligen dieser Welt. Jetzt ist das ja noch eine Weile hin, kann ja noch ganz viel passieren. Was allerdings unwahrscheinlich erscheint, zumindest zum Stand jetzt, ist, dass Fener sich fürs internationale Geschäft qualifizieren würde. Da würde sich jetzt, wenn wir schon so viel über Finanzen gesprochen haben, wirklich die Anschlussfrage stellen, was würde es denn bedeuten für einen Verein wie Fenerbahce? Oder es kann ja anderen oben auch noch passieren. Das ist ja alles sehr, sehr eng da oben drin. Wenn sie unter dem Financial Fairplay schon leidend jetzt auch noch die Zusatzeinnahmen aus der Europa League verlieren würden, sind die hoch?
Die haben sie vor allem nicht, weil der Vorstand zuvor sämtliche Einnahmen verwendet hat. Also das ist bei den zukünftigen Einnahmen.
Genau.
Also für irgendwelche Kredite wurden Zuschauereinnahmen der Zukunft verwendet, um irgendwelche Kredite zu bekommen zum Beispiel. Ja, also das Problem ist riesengroß bei den großen Vereinen. Tatsächlich weiß ich auch nicht, wie sie da alle rauskommen wurden. Also der Staat braucht selbst die Kohle, um jetzt nicht ständig wieder noch weitere Steuerleichterungen zu machen. Und wie gesagt, Financial Fairplay ist ja auch und da ein Thema. Also da guckt ja die UEFA auch drauf, ob da in der Richtung was passiert. Man muss ja diese Bilanzen auch offenlegen. Man muss diese Steuerausgaben, die man wahrscheinlich hat, ja auch offenlegen. Und dann kannst du nicht sagen, übrigens der Staat hat gesagt, ich brauchst du jetzt nicht zahlen. Also das kannst du ja auch nicht verargumentieren. Der neue Fenerbahce-Präsident versucht damit eben einer der reichsten Menschen in der Türkei, hat eine riesen Holding. Wirklich, ja, viele Ableger großer internationaler Marken liegen in seinem Rechtsbereich quasi. Er versucht da mit irgendwelchen Amel-Sponsorings, mit Stadionsponsorings und so weiter, da Geld reinzuschustern. Aber zum einen reicht das nicht, und zum anderen darf es auch nicht immer in die Mannschaft investieren. Das ist das große, große Problem. Und deswegen kam jetzt eben auch die Aussage, ja, vielleicht überlegen wir mal, nicht am Europapokal teilzunehmen. Dann sind wir nicht in Financial Fairplay geboten und können die Mannschaft dann nochmal investieren. Aber sie checken halt einfach nicht, dass das nicht reichen wird. Also da ist einfach in den letzten Jahren so viel falsch gelaufen, dass man das jetzt nicht auf in den nächsten ein, zwei Jahren einfach wieder alles reparieren kann.
Ja, vor allem ist es ja dann wieder nur so eine kurzfristige Lösung. Also langfristig würde ja nur gesundes Wirtschaften das wieder langsam bereinigen. Und das wäre ja wieder so eine einmalige Finanzspritze. Und gut, wenn er jetzt sagen würde, macht mit dem Geld was ihr wollt, ihr kriegt das jetzt einfach geschenkt, dann ginge das vielleicht noch halbwegs. Aber selbst dann kann man ja eigentlich davon ausgehen, wenn sich das Rad so weiter dreht, wie es bisher gelaufen ist, dann kommt man früh oder später wieder in eine ähnliche Situation.
Genau. Und eben, ich glaube auch nicht, dass Adelj Kocce erwartet, das Geld zurückzubekommen. Da ist er glaube ich auch zu viel zu fair Fan. Und da traut er sich glaube ich auch nicht, das auch zurückzufordern. Aber trotzdem, da gibt es ja so viele Bauschen. Selbst so eine 50 Millionen Euro-Spritze, die es jetzt glaube ich neulich gegeben haben soll, das ist ja nur ein Tropfen auf dem heißen Stein. Und es kommt ja schon der nächste Sommer, in dem Fenerbahce jetzt zum Beispiel ein paar Leihspiele hat, die man abgeben muss. Die müssen ja irgendwie dann nachbesetzen. Andre Ayuh zum Beispiel, Slimani, das sind ja alles Leihspieler. Und die sind Stammspieler bei Fenerbahce, die ja dann ersetzt werden müssen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass Fenerbahce in dem Sommer ein bisschen was ausgegeben hat. Und damit hat dieser Umbruch getan. Nee, es muss ja weitergehen. Und die Mannschaft ist ja dann auch wieder ein bisschen älter. Also da ist noch viel, viel zu gehen. Aber dazu muss man auch sagen, es ist nicht nur ein exklusives Problem von Fenerbahce, sondern der andere auch. Der Vorteil von Galatasaray ist, dass man relativ hohe Einnahmen hat. Auch jetzt kurz davor ist, das Vereinsgelände zu verkaufen, weil es in einem sehr, sehr teuren Gebiet steht und man woanders günstiger trainieren könnte. Da kamen auch schon ein paar Einnahmen rein. Da gibt es auch schon große Probleme. So ist es nicht. Aber bei Fenerbahce sind sie in den letzten Jahren auch, weil der Präsident 19 Jahre lang so autoritär regiert hat und nach außen hin so wenig gedrungen ist, dass man davon überhaupt nichts hinbekommt. Also die Probleme von Fenerbahce sind jetzt, man hat es vermutet, aber jetzt hat man zum ersten Mal so richtig Gewissheit und auch die Information, wie schlimm es in dem Verein steht.
Wahnsinn. Und wie ist die Stimmung bei den Fußballinteressierten Türken? Es ist ja vom sportlich gesehen spannend, gleichzeitig sind aber auch Mannschaften jetzt in schwierigeren Situationen, die eine sehr große Fanbasis haben. Also wie ist jetzt gerade so die Stimmung im Land? Freut man sich darüber, dass mal andere Namen oben stehen? Macht man sich eher Sorgen oder rebellieren auch die großen Vereine? Es ist ja wahrscheinlich auch für die Fernsehsender, die ja einen großen Teil der Einnahmen ausmachen, wird es ja auch wichtig sein, dass die Vereine mit großer Fanbasis irgendwie auch oben mitspielen.
Das ist sicherlich ein Thema. Also das ist gerade für die TV-Anstalten, die natürlich davon leben, dass Galafena und Besiktas, dass die Fans ihre Abos abschließen und eben auch gucken und die Zuschauerzahlen oder die Sendezeiten entsprechend auch genutzt werden. Aber in dem Fall hat man schon eine Befürchtung. Da kommt auch dazu, dass im Ruhpokal der Erfolg ja auch ausbleibt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass da auch und das ist dann auch der gleiche Sender. Da gibt es schon ernste Miene nach so einem Spiel. Und dann ist auch das Thema Nationalmannschaft kommt ja auch noch dazu, die ja auch nicht viel besser ist, obwohl sie deutlich mehr Perspektive hat als viele Vereine in der Türkei, weil es eine gute, junge Mannschaft ist. Es zieht sich gerade wie so ein roter Faden, dass die Stimmung im Fußballland eine schlechte ist, aber gerade bei den jüngeren Fußballfans oder sagen wir mal der neuen Generation kommt die Franzi schon insgeheim, was da gerade passiert. Dass die Großen gerade so ein bisschen das eigentlich bekommen, was sie ja nicht seit Jahren verdienen für ihre schlechte Arbeit. Aber ich glaube gerade so diese ganzen Geldgeber, die haben schon ihre Sorgen. Und was ich noch vergessen habe, was auch wirklich ein Grund ist für diesen Wandel, ist auch natürlich der Videoschützrichter. Das ist ein Thema, das man auch besprechen sollte.
Videoschützrichter, kaum ein Thema hier im Rasenfunk.
Ist auch nicht ein Thema, weil es heißt ja, es soll ja passieren, dass diese großen Vereine auch mal ein bisschen Unterstützung erhalten von den Schützrichtern, dass dann auch mal ein Foul mal durchgeht und so weiter.
Und das geht jetzt nicht um einen Videoschützrichter?
Das geht nicht mehr.
Ja, aber dann macht ihr es ja falsch. Das heißt, der Fußball ist gerechter geworden.
Das ist tatsächlich gerechter geworden. Also man muss nur auf die Tabelle gucken. Ich glaube, dass die Tabelle tatsächlich auch damit etwas zu tun hat. Zwar gehen die großen Vereine auf die Barrikaden und versuchen, und nutzen natürlich auch diese großen Medienmacht, die sie haben, um da Stimmung gegen Videoschützrichter und allem Drum und Dran zu machen. Teilweise vielleicht auch berechtigt, weil es tatsächlich auch wie in der Bundesliga letztens in der ersten Saison auch große Probleme beim Wargap in der Türkei tatsächlich. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist der Fußball gerechter geworden durch den Widerschützrichter. Und man muss nur auf die Tabelle gucken. Also das hat schon mit einem Grund, dass man hier und da korrigiert, dass hin und da auch mehr rote Karten auch für die Großen kommen, dass da mehr Elfmeter gegen sie gefiffen wird. Es liegt ja auf der Hand. Also du kannst ja nicht auf ein Video gucken und dann sehen, dass es so gewollt ist und dann trotzdem anders entscheiden.
Ja, du kannst immer noch sagen, der Schützrichter hat es wahrgenommen und anders bewertet, deswegen können wir nicht einladen. Das ist aber dann auch der deutsche Weg of doing Video Assistant Referees.
Genau. In der Türkei schießt sich so ein sehr emotionales Thema. Der Schützrichter ist der schlechteste Mensch der Welt. Aber ich finde, im Großen und Ganzen geht das schon in die richtige Richtung.
Sieht man in der Türkei auf den Leinwänden, was sich die Video Referees angucken? Nein. Auch nicht?
Nein, es gibt ja auch, es gibt schon Stadien, bei denen es sowas gibt, aber es ist, glaube ich, chancengleich hat auch, dass man das dann nicht überall sehen kann. Aber im Fernsehen ist die Einbindung schon sehr, sehr…
Ist es besser als so, wie es im deutschen Fernsehen gemacht hat?
Ich finde es tatsächlich besser, ja. Also es gab Einzel-Zwischenfälle, in denen das dann nochmal verbessert werden musste, weil es gab tatsächlich, bei ein, zwei Spielen gab es einen Verbindungsabbruch. So ein Video steht sich da und kann ich es sogar erklären, das war sehr, sehr, sehr zäh. Das war sehr dramatisch, gerade für Elea, den wir vorhin besprochen hatten. Fenerbahce hat zu Hause gegen Basakse gespielt. 0-0, 81 Minuten, rotes Signal beim TV-Sender, Informationen vom Kommentator, Leute, nur damit ihr wisst, es ist gerade eine Verbindung zum Videoschicht sich da abgebrochen. Der Schichtsteller hat keine Verbindung zu dem. Zack, Tor, Basakse hier, Abseits-Stellung, Schichtsteller geht abseits. War keiner, war kein Abseits. Hat versucht, die ganze Zeit Verbindung aufzubauen, hat aber viel zu lange gedauert und dann hat er weiterspielen lassen. Im Nachhinein ist aber rausgekommen, es war kein Abseits. Hätte man beim Videoschichtsteller sofort erkennen können, dass es kein Abseits ist, natürlich fatal. Also das war richtig, richtig fatal. Dann gab es einen Zwischenfall, auch wenn es der Verband abschaltet, hat man aber, es gibt genug Information darüber, dass es aber wirklich so war, dass warum auch immer die Spielerschichtsteller nicht am Platz saßen bei einem Spiel, in einer bestimmten Szene und dann auch er da sich nicht rückversichern konnte. Sodass jetzt ein paar Optimierungsmaßnahmen ergriffen wurden. Man sieht jetzt die Schiedsrichter auch deutlich besser. Es ist nicht mehr so ein dunkler Raum, sondern man sieht wirklich, wer da sitzt. Man sieht auch auf deren Bildschirm, was sie gerade gucken, welche Sequenz sie gerade gucken. Da wird es auch synchronisiert mit dem TV-Bild, dass man ungefähr genau das gerade live sieht, was sie auch sehen. Aber ein bisschen Chancengleichheit hat man dadurch schon überlassen können.
Interessant. Wir haben jetzt nicht mehr viel Zeit, aber gibt es noch irgendein Team, wo du sagst, das ist jetzt so wichtig, da würdest du uns noch gerne 30 Sekunden sagen, warum das bemerkenswert ist, wo die aktuell stehen?
Ankara Gücü zum Beispiel ist ein interessanter Verein. Ich habe vorhin gesagt, es gibt eine Vereinbarkeit, die keinen Trainingsplatz und keinen Stadion hat. Ankara Gücü ist ein Verein, hat eine große Tradition, also eine riesengroße Tradition in den letzten Jahren. Durchgereicht sportlich, auch da wird –welche Überraschungen? wirtschaftlich viele Fehler gemacht. Der Verein hatte mal vor Jahren bei Roger Le Maire Trainer, Darius Wassel war im Sturm, Jeremy Meñez im Mittelfeld, also unfassbaren Kader zusammengestellt, die natürlich dann alle ein halbes Jahr später gehen mussten.
Und das ist der Verein aus Ankara, der jetzt dann auch das Stadion bekommt, oder hätte er das nur bekommen, wenn jetzt die EM-Firka vergeben worden wären?
Es muss einfach ein Stadion, weil in Ankara gibt es drei Vereine, die spielen alle irgendwo. Der Verein hat auch keinen Trainingsplatz.
Wo trainieren die dann, also wie geht das?
Ja, an irgendwelchen städtischen Sportanlagen. Und trotzdem dann irgendwie da auf Platz 11 zu landen, ist für mich schon ein Erfolg. Die haben auch zum Beispiel Fenerbahce geschlagen, auswärts 3-1. Aber die letzten zwei, drei Spiele haben ein bisschen Durchhänge gehabt. Und jetzt haben sie einen Trainer entlassen.
Als Aussteiger auf der Bellenplatz 11, liegend mit fünf Punkten Vorsprung auf den Abstiegsgang.
Genau. Und ohne Stadion, ohne Trainingsplatz, auch mit einer Mannschaft.
Ohne Trainer. Ich meine, irgendwie ist es auch stringent.
Das ist stringent. Da ist dann ein Wagen gesagt, okay, dann ziehen wir es durch, jetzt auch kein Torwart.
Ab jetzt Training nur noch ohne Ball.
Ab nächste Woche dann auch kein Torwart mehr, brauchen wir auch nicht. Aber es ist so ein bisschen noch, also ich habe erzählt, dass viele Vereine in der Türkei angefangen haben, sehr professionell zu agieren. Also eben gerade Basak Seheri, Malatyaspor, Kasim Paşa, auch Konyaspor, sehr, sehr interessante Vereine. Also da passiert schon sehr, sehr viel, aber dann hast du eben auch dann so Fälle wie Ankara, Gücü, wo es halt dann in die komplett andere Richtung läuft.
Ach, es ist einfach spannend. Ein bisschen bereuchtet es doch, dass wir jetzt erst über die Super League sprechen, aber wir können ja auf jeden Fall in der Rückrunde nochmal draufgucken. Wenn wir die Zeit finden, das war Fatih Demireli atdemireli.de auf Twitter vom sehr empfehlenswerten Sportmagazin Sokrates. Danke dir, Fatih, dass du mal hergekommen bist hier in die Rasenfunk-Studios. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war ein weiterer internationaler Kurzpass. Und morgen gibt es schon den nächsten. Das heißt, am Mittwoch wird schon der nächste Rasenfunk Kurzpass erscheinen. Außerdem gibt es noch zwei Schlusskonferenzen in dieser Woche und dann ja irgendwann den Rasenfunk Royale. Ich wünsche euch eine gute Zeit. Bis bald mal wieder.